on va monsieur marc bauer
qui pourra nous faire part de son regard
d'avocats spécialisé en droit fiscal
patrimonial sur le recours à de tels
montages et leur nature juridique et
peut-être il pourra également peut-être
pas de position un petit peu sur le
secret et quand tour la profession
d'avocat et nous donner sa position cela
permettra d'avoir un peu d'interactions
ou d'interactivité entre nous genre je
remercie frédéric iannucci d'avoir tendu
la perche sur le le rôle des avocats qui
ne sont pas des intermédiaires
financiers comme les autres en tout cas
je tiens à le rappeler mais je dois
d'abord commencé par dire que c'est
c'est paradise peppers je me demande
comment ils vont faire pour trouver un
nouveau nom à prévoir
dont il parlait pour les pandora paper
ce donc qui commence par un p après
panama après paradise avec quel va être
le prochain nom bon qui nous apprennent
pas grand chose sur les techniques
utilisées ni lait ni les juridictions
concernées les îles vierges britanniques
le panama la suisse je dirais c'est
toujours les mêmes jugent suspectes
mais bon il faut quand même rappeler moi
je me suis plongé dans ce que les
journalistes ont bien voulu dévoiler
et tous tous ces schémas ne sont pas
nécessairement frauduleux il faut quand
même bien distinguer que il ya la fraude
la côte est qui est sanctionnable pour
lequel l'administration fiscale est là
et use de tous les moyens prévus par la
loi pour la réprimer et l'optimisation
qui dans notre société de liberté reste
encore un droit même si le mot fait
tâche maintenant même nous on évite de
les deux de l'utiliser mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que quel soit
agressive ou pas agressive elle est soit
du bon côté de la loi soit du mauvais
côté de la loi et il ya quand même des
marqueurs objectifs qui permettent de
de la cerner et la classe et
ensuite il faut distinguer
les problématiques de fiscalité et les
problématiques de confidentialité je
pense que on ne peut pas retirer aux
gens le le souhait de rester discret sur
leur investissement pour autant
évidemment que l'argent qu'ils
investissent soit de l'argent qui n'est
pas sale ou teintés
avec quand même effectivement on peut
dire une réserve sur les personnalités
exposées publiquement un politiquement
les fameuses
qui l ont un devoir évidemment plus
lourd que le commun des mortels quant à
la transparence de son patrimoine moi
j'ai quand même été frappé qu'un homme
comme tony blair possède enfin est
acquis un tel patrimoine fin cette fois
même ça pose question
même si je ne lui fais pas de procès
d'intention enfin c'est une cinquantaine
de maisons au royaume uni face et quand
même des grosses sommes
et puis je voudrais également précisé le
rôle des avocats qui ne sont pas des
intermédiaires financiers nous les
avocats nous avons une déontologie très
strictes nous ne pouvons pas participer
à la commission d'une infraction et si
nous le faisons de toute façon nous ne
sommes pas protégés par le secret
professionnel le secret professionnel
c'est le prophète le secret
professionnel de nos clients et c'est
dans leur intérêt que la loi nous nous
la donner donc nous ne sommes pas des
intermédiaires financiers comme les
autres et le
législateur n'a rien à gagner à nous
prendre pour cible pour réprimer une
fraude qui peut parfaitement être
réprimés autrement sans aller nous nous
perquisitionné dans nos cabinets parce
que nous attaquer s'est aussi attaqué la
justice et s'est attaqué le consentement
à l'impôt
nous avocats nous nous participons
à l'expression de cette justice qui pour
trouve aboutir à une décision doit
entendre non seulement l'accusation mais
également la défense et cette
distinction entre le conseil et la
défense sur laquelle le sénat s'est
prononcé récemment est une distinction
qui n'existe pas en tout cas pas dans
les textes européens qui ont une norme
une autorité supérieure à la loi
française et je pense à la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme en
particulier et sa jurisprudence qui ne
distingue pas le secret de l'avocat dans
son exercice de conseils de celui de sa
mission de défense il est indispensable
que nos clients puissent nous parler
sans craindre qu'on puisse les dénoncer
d'une manière ou d'une autre
alors la suite de ses portes de ras
peppers est ce que une fois de plus ils
vont justifier une loi de circonstance
qui va encore donner encore plus de
pouvoir l'administration fiscale pour
réprimer la fraude moi je tiens quand
même à rappeler deux choses la première
c'est que les textes existent
en l'espace des dix dernières années
l'arsenal juridique pénale de
l'administration fiscale s'est
considérablement renforcée à tel point
que les limites sont probablement
atteinte déjà je vous rappelle que pas
plus tard qu après demain le conseil
constitutionnel va statuer sur la
compatibilité avec la constitution de la
procédure elle 23 c du livre des
procédures fiscales
755 du code général des impôts est
peut-être qu'il va valider le texte
peut-être qu'ils valent déclarée
inconstitutionnelle peut-être qu'il va
mettre des réserves d'interprétation
mais une chose est sûre c'est que il va
être difficile d'aller plus loin que ce
mécanisme qui permet à l'administration
fiscale je le rappelle d'interroger
quelqu'un qui n'a pas satisfait à ses
obligations déclaratives de déclaration
des comptes étrangers pour lui demander
d'où vient son patrimoine et s'il ne
peut pas donner de réponse satisfaisante
de le taxer de taxer le comme le solde
du compte bancaire lalanne est la plus
élevée le sol le plus élevé pardon du
compte bancaire au titre des 10
dernières années aux droits de mutation
à titre gratuit aux tarifs non par an
c'est-à-dire de 60%
là peut-être que nous arrivons à la
limite de l'exercice consistant à
renforcer systématiquement les pouvoirs
de l'administration fiscale et puis la
deuxième chose et dernière pour cette
conclusion introduction par donc je
voulais dire c'est que l'administration
fiscale s'est énormément renforcé en
termes de savoir faire ces dix dernières
années je vous livre une petite anecdote
qui qui concerne la première cellule
woerth savez pour régulariser les gens
qui étaient sur la liste la fameuse
liste hsbc
moi j'avais un dossier qui nous incluons
qui n'était pas sur cette liste mais qui
s'était laissée embringuer embarqué à
acheter les titres d'une bille haye qui
portait un investissement qu'il voulait
faire et que le vendeur avait
manifestement loger là parce que
l'argent qu'il avait mis était pas
forcément très clair et mais mon client
lui voulait faire cet investissement
le seul moyen c'est est de racheter les
titres d'un vivier haye comme il savait
que c'était pas très bien il n'en avait
pas parlé à son conseil l'occurrence
mois il avait fait ça dans son coin avec
une banque suisse et puis quand il m'a
dit ça je dis il faut aller directement
profité de la cellule woerth et je me
souviens d'être d'avoir éteint en
entretien reçus par le directeur chargé
de cette cellule monsieur bignon de
mémoire et quand j'ai commencé à lui
expliqué schéma en historienne viviane
il m'a regardé et m'a dit c'est quoi une
ville en 1989 savais pas ce que c'était
une vieille et bien je peux vous dire
que ça ça a changé l'administration
fiscale a considérablement renforcé son
expertise grâce aux campagnes de
régularisation qui lui ont permis
finalement de voir l'autre côté des
opérations puisque les conseils sont
venus expliquer ce qu'ils avaient fait
pour les régulariser ils ont acquis une
connaissance de la pratique très très
très
au niveau et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons une
administration bien formés qui connaît
bien ces techniques et qui peut ainsi
tout à fait réprimer les schémas qui
aurait été abusifs ce qui n'est pas je
le rappelle le cas de tous les schémas
dénoncée par les
pandores ap perth je vous remercie
ainsi beaucoup je me permets de vous
relancer nous avons un peu d'avancé
vous avez dit concernant l'optimisation
il ya des facteurs objectifs je pourrais
en reparler vous pourriez nous dire
quels sont les facteurs objectifs entre
la fraude et l'optimisation c'est par
exemple si vous ne respectez pas la loi
vous êtes dans la fraude si vous la
voyez si vous la respectez vous êtes à
priori dans l'optimisation après il ya
aussi la butte droit et donc si vous ne
respectez pas si vous respectez la loi
mais pas son esprit vous êtes également
dans la fraude mais tout ça vient de la
jurisprudence on a quand même la
capacité en tout cas nous avocats de
guider nos clients pour l'heure les
accompagner là où ils doivent se trouver
c'est-à-dire du bon côté de la ligne
merci de ces de ces précisions à
l'occasion des panamas paper en 2016
c'est le cabinet maussac fonséca qui
avait été pointée mais on se rend compte
avec ces nouvelles révélations que ce
cabinet maussac fonséca n'était pas un
cas isolé mais a fait école et à de
nombreux concurrents de par le monde
cette année on nous parle du cabinet
baker mckenzie 5000 avocats présents
dans 46 pays du monde mackenzie au koné
qui se sont occupé d'autres affaires en
france il ya quelques temps aux mots de
la pandémie
14 cabinets sont cités dans ces
révélations dépendra papers
créateur donc de sociétés offshore
société anonyme offshore évidemment le
but c'est d'échapper à l'impôt c'est de
bénéficier d'une totale opacité et
d'échapper aussi aux juges et aux lois
des personnes étaient politiques sont
cités ça fait beaucoup de mal bien
évidemment à la république a la
confiance de nos concitoyens
600 nos concitoyens sont cités dans ces
dans ces documents dans ses révélations
on apprend à des cours et on a la
confirmation que des états membres de
l'union européenne sont eux-mêmes addict
de ces pratiques régulières on a cité le
luxembourg au mois de février dernier
dans la sphère open luxe et cette fois
ci c'est chypre dont il est question à
ma connaissance ces deux états sont
membres de l'union européenne
ce n'est pas sans poser de problèmes
politique de fond auquel il faudrait
s'attaquer alors ces dossiers illustrent
parfaitement le caractère systémique de
ces industries de l'offshore on n'est
pas dans un dysfonctionnement d'une
économie libéralisée mondialisé dérégulé
non c'est au coeur du système il faut
des clients il faut les territoires
complaisant il faut des banquiers oui il
faut des avocats des cabinets des
notaires des prestataires des prête noms
des sociétés écrans etc etc et tout cela
a fait système et tout cela organise
l'opacité
alors j'ai quelques questions à
soumettre à nos invités aujourd'hui
tout d'abord messi iannucci donc sur les
600 français qui ont dit qu'ils sont
cités vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
comment vous traitiez ce genre de sujet
mais est ce que vous pourriez préciser
la stratégie qui est la vôtre de quels
moyens disposez vous parce que là les
journalistes nous ont rappelé qu'ils
avaient exploité 12 millions de
documents j'imagine la masse de travail
humain qu'il faut pour exploiter ces
données alors je sais que monsieur
darmana en 2018 avait créé une police
fiscale de 25 individus sans doute très
compétent mais c'est 25 et dans le même
temps depuis vingt ans la dgesip a perdu
38 mille emplois ça n'est pas non plus
sans conséquence monsieur ministre du
sob l'aspect manière disait qu'après les
panama papers nous avions récupéré 200
millions d'euros vous nuancer un peu je
crois avoir noté que vous parliez de 176
millions d'euros là aussi le décalage
est assez saisissant entre ces chiffres
récupérer et ceux qui sont censés nous
nous échapper ensuite deuxième point
jour évoquées c'est la chaîne de
responsabilités effectivement dans la
commission denquête nous avions mené en
2013 ici on peut pas s'évader sans un
peu d'être évidemment
et je me souviens d'une intervention
d'un d'une personnalité qu'on avait
auditionné monsieur marc roche à
l'époque rejoint liste pour le monde
correspondant à londres fin connaisseur
de la city et du monde de la finance et
de ses acteurs il avait dit je cite les
banques ne sont qu'un petit élément d'un
réseau de complicités plus vaste dans
lequel on trouve des bureaux d'avocats
des cabinets comptables des conseillers
financiers alors évident on entend sur
cet argument qui consiste à dire
optimisation évasion mais je rappellerai
cette citation fameuse d'initiés qui
était le sanctionner l'échiquier le
gouvernement britannique entre 74 et 79
et il a eu ce mot un jour la différence
entre une optimisation et l'évasion
fiscale est dans l'épaisseur l'épaisseur
du mur d'une prison voilà chacun en
pensera ce qu'il veut mais j'ai trouvé
ça assez drôle troisième point qui a été
évoqué dans le chai parrinello c'est la
liste des paradis fiscaux en europe
augey l'union européenne aucun état
membre ne peut être considéré par le par
la commission comme un paradis fiscal or
là on a deux pays majeurs
luxembourg notamment mais je pense
également à chapeau à chypre pardo on
pourrait citer malte on pourrait
s'intéresser aux pays bas aux pays bas
avec des sièges des holdings l'irlande
un statut fiscal un peu particulier
aussi or pour l'union européenne nous
revoilà pas de paradis fiscal au sein
l'union européenne je pense que là il ya
déjà un deuxième trou dans le bouclier
plus les complicités que malheureusement
on constate on a cité tony blair on a
cité dsk tout ça est absolument
dommageable fondamentalement dommageable
et il faudrait qu'on s'intéresse de près
à ces sujets merci on cesse pas faire
nous les avocats et il est important que
notre secret professionnel soit protégée
parce que et je l' ai déjà dit en
introduction mais je vais le répéter
parce que je pense qu'il faut marteler
le message notre secret professionnel
n'est pas pour nous protéger nous
exonérer de nos responsabilités il est
là dans l'intérêt des justiciables et
donc dans l'intérêt de la justice
en matière fiscale l'intérêt de la
justice rejoint le consentement à
l'impôt ce consentement à l'impôt qui
est si précieux pour notre démocratie
si le le si les lois ne permettent pas
aux contribuables de les appliquer avec
discernement et dans le respect de leurs
droits fondamentaux de liberté m qui
sont protégés par notre constitution
alors indirectement mais nécessairement
c'est le consentement à l'impôt lui-même
qui est abaissée et c'est extrêmement
grave donc en prenant les avocats pour
cible comme le font un certain nombre de
deux deux sénateurs et de domaine j'ai
autant de cette table je pense que vous
vous trompez de cible oui il y à des
intermédiaires financiers qu'ils
commercialisent des schémas frauduleux
non il n'y a pas d'avocats parmi eux en
tout cas pas d'avocats français
j'ai entendu ce site est livré à la
vindicte populaire le nom du cabinet
baker & mckenzie qui est cité dans l'est
paradise des perdants ap perth
je mets au défi de prouver qu'ils ont
mal agi et
s'ils ont mal agi ils seront sanctionnés
mais connaissant la réputation et la
qualité des professionnels en tout cas
en france de ce cabinet j'en serais
personnellement extrêmement surpris
ça c'était le premier point sur le
sur les comment dire la chaîne de
responsabilités avec les avocats qui
sont mis dedans la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire
concerne la dictature de la transparence
que l'on essaie de nous imposer je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il y a le livre
le respect le droit constitutionnel au
respect de sa vie privée qui fait que le
secret n'est pas honteux des gens ont
des intérêts parfaitement légitime à ne
pas vouloir que leur affaire privée soit
mis sur la place publique donc arrêtons
à vouloir mettre de la transparence
partout c'est vrai en revanche qu'il ya
des catégories de citoyens qui mérite
une place particulière ceux qui aspirent
à exercer des fonctions publiques
doivent s'attendre à ce que les citoyens
scrutent leur affaire privée et ça
paraît être un droit assez fondamental
pour le coup à mettre en oeuvre mais on
est face à un problème d'éthique une
frontière à tracer entre
la répression de la fraude d'un côté et
le droit à la liberté au respect de sa
vie privée de l'autre votre honorable
assemblée participent au processus
législatif qui vise à réglementer enfin
comment dire résoudre ces problèmes
d'éthique donc en trouvant la bonne
frontière entre ces principes
contradictoires au dessus de vous il ya
le conseil constitutionnel il ya la cour
de justice de l'union européenne et il y
à là concours open et droits de l'homme
qui eux aussi ont leur conception des
choses en espérant qu'elle soit à peu
près similaire mais il est important de
savoir que la transparence absolue est
une folie et je la dénonce je la dénonce
pour le citoyen lambda qui a le droit au
respect de sa vie privée et de ses
placements qu'il ne doit pas retrouver
sur la place publique le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré la publicité
du registre des trusts
[Musique]